Oh No
okay you get the point but let's look at
just House level say this glass is your
brand-new fancy iPhone tens battery and
this apple juice not actually made by
Apple is the juice coming from a charger
now say this is the charge coming from
that included five watt charger and this
is the charge coming from Apple's fast
charging 29 watt USBC charger the five
watt charger takes three hours and seven
minutes to fill up the battery to a
hundred percent the twenty nine watt two
hours and two minutes but here's the
catch this twenty nine watt charger
which Apple recommends for fast charging
the new iPhones costs fifty dollars and
you need to buy this USB C to lightning
cord for an extra $25 $75 for faster
charging Yolo here are my tricks to
charge your iPhone faster and for twenty
dollars or less
check this out that $75 twenty nine watt
option took two hours and two minutes to
charge up an iPhone ten to a hundred
percent but apples 12 watt charger took
two hours and twelve minutes that's why
if you've got an iPhone 6 or older or
one of those brand new iPhones I suggest
you start using the 12 watt charger or
better yet buy this anchors $11 24 watt
power port elite 2 has two ports costs
less and charge the iPhone 8 8 plus and
10 just as fast as the iPad charger you
can use the cord Apple gives you in the
box but if you're looking to avoid cord
split ends get a braided option like
this anchor power line plus lightning
nylon braided one yeah clearly anchor is
my current favorite seseri company
weight cords
isn't this 2017 what about wireless
charging wireless charging is easy and
convenient but in my tests charging the
new iPhones with Wireless pads wasn't
much faster than the five watt charger
least not yet a coming iOS software
update should make it faster Apple sells
the $60 Belkin boost up and Mophie
wireless charging base but I actually
found the Samsung fast charge wireless
pad to charge slightly faster than the
other two and if you're going to really
splurge go for the $90 samsung wireless
charging convertible it's especially
good for the iPhone 10 since you don't
have to pick up the phone to unlock it
with face ID no matter what charger you
use don't forget the simple software
tricks to speed things up if you're
really crunched for time put the phone
in airplane mode or low-power mode also
lower the brightness and turn off
notifications but if you remember one
thing forget these five watch photos